top hollywood action romp two most
recently
an absolute thirst trap wow i've seen
the franchise take detours into
different
genres set pieces and concepts some more
successful than
others and everything the franchise has
attempted
accomplished and even failed at is in
resident evil village one way or another
from a genre defining breakthrough to
some of the more
debatable entries resident evil village
is the most
resident evil game of them all
let me break this down the foundation of
resident evil village
lies on well the actual village it's a
sprawling maze-like
area with dead ends locked doors and
obtuse paths
but as the game progresses it connects
to the other areas unraveling new ones
to be discovered rewarding the player
with keys and items that compel them
to backtrack and re-explore it this was
a trope defined by the franchise's very
first entry back in 1996
and it was a revolution for horror games
and the first to define a genre
the survival horror genre it took
elements from adventure games with
exploration
backtracking and item-based puzzles and
then apply to survival to it
by giving the player very limited
resources and enemies that soaked up
that precious
precious ammunition it was a slow paced
slog through a maze-like environment of
narrow halls
forcing the player to make life or death
choices around
every corner of the confusingly designed
oswell spencer mansion this is a
characteristic that would come and go
through the franchise with backtracking
and puzzles being last seen most
prominently
in the fourth entry in the series code
veronica back in 2000.
it did make its grand return in resident
evil 7 but
even then the exploration was pale in
comparison to one
two in veronica that is until
resident evil village the village opens
and unravels similarly to the original
oswell mansion from one and the raccoon
city police department from
two or even more accurately like code
veronica's european gothic
palace and victorian mansion especially
considering its similar aesthetic to
lady dimitresk's castle
in resident evil village speaking of big
lady d let's talk about being chased
as you navigate the halls of
demotresque's castle she
and her daughters will stalk and follow
you as you desperately try to find
keys and items to unlock and open other
areas
this iconic and terrifying
characteristic comes straight from
resident evil 3
nemesis resident evil 3 threw a wrench
in the tropes that one and two had
created
trading off the slow pacing for urgency
and paranoia that big baddy nemesis
could bust through at any moment
a towering invincible foe that stalks
you constantly
ramping up the pressure when you least
expect it
like many ideas of the resident evil
franchise the mechanic of constantly
being pursued wouldn't make a return
until again resident evil 7 with jack
baker
but it wasn't fully mastered until
resident evil 2 remake with mr
x the resident evil 2 remake took jack
baker's stalking mechanic
and launched it to the nth degree with
mr x making him a towering
silent goon that slammed through
anything to get you
mr x did make an appearance in the og
resident evil 2 during the b
scenario but not to the same degree as
nemesis and capcom
but at full force in the remake lady
dimitrisk is the embodiment of both jack
baker and
mr x a family woman just looking after
her own while also being an
intimidatingly huge individual
big i'm gonna [ __ ] you up real hard
energy
while you're traversing villages many
different environments there'll be
treasure to find animals to hunt
and this jolly old fella to find solace
in as you sell items upgrade weapons
and buy new ones that you can organize
in your tetris-like inventory
all of this is thanks to resident evil
4. residual 4 ripped the franchise away
from its fixed camera angles expanded
your arsenal and turn the harrowing odds
against one zombie up to 11
favoring overwhelming stress over pure
horror
a near copy of village's encounters with
a lichens
especially in its opening sequence when
you're overwhelmingly outnumbered and
have to barricade yourself into a house
four introduce the tetris-like inventory
case the treasure hunting currency
and a merchant to sell items with most
of these mechanics are defining a four's
identity
and interestingly never appeared in the
franchise again
that is until now with village some of
four's influences on village may not be
as apparent
as others however probably the most
notorious area
in village is house beneviento which not
only features an adorable baby but
these terrifying ghost dolls which
aren't
entirely new to the franchise while 4
was in development it had gone through
several different prototypes until
coming to what it is today
one internal version of the game was
known as the hallucination version
in this prototype build there was a room
known simply as
the doll room where leon kennedy would
fight against these pesky
19th century porcelain dolls while this
didn't end up making the cut for
resident evil 4 it was revived and
cemented in village
leaning full force into the supernatural
elements that resident evil only toyed
with
behind the curtains and it gets to be a
little nice wink and nod to us resident
evil nerds who caught it
and with no reasonable transition let's
talk about chris redfield
an overarching plot device in
residential village is chris
who swoops into the opening moments of
the game killing ethan's wife and
kidnapping his baby
chris is among the longest standing
characters in the franchise first
appearing in resident evil 1 alongside
jill valentine
but the game to have the most defining
impact on his character
shaping him into the bulky military head
that he is now
is resident evil 5. taking him from the
soft face boy from resident evil 1 and
code veronica and establishing
his military attitude and muscles
mechanically village didn't really take
that much from the co-op focused five
aside from carrying the weight of
redfield's pecs but when resident evil 6
rolled around it had completely launched
the franchise into full-blown hollywood
antics with over-the-top
action and a sprawling cast of
characters that make even a soap opera
jealous
village captures six essence at its
finest near the closing hours
when we step into the shoes of chris
tricep redfield and go
buck wild on waves of likens all call of
duty style
all of which comes to a close with a
mushroom cloud
while resident evil 6 is notoriously
divisive among fans for being a
full-on hollywood action game it seems
that village couldn't help itself from
going
a little off the rails once again but
hey at least it didn't have a zombie
t-rex monster thing
right
obviously resident evil village carried
a lot over from its predecessor resident
evil 7
while 7 softly returned to its
exploration and backtracking roots
its biggest contribution to the
franchise was its change to a first
person perspective
resident evil 7 was the first true
reimagining the franchise had seen in a
decade since resident
iv but this time around making it first
person leaning all
in on horror and lightly attempting to
revisit the franchise's dna with an
emphasis on tight spaces exploration and
arbitrary locked doors
this is something that village doubles
down on more interesting is how the game
is structured showcasing resident evil
7's antagonists
as a family front and center with each
foe having their own distinct
area to explore and maneuver through a
prominent trait carried over into
village's
narrative structure when being
introduced to the four lords
resident evil 7 felt like an attempt to
reposition the franchise with a new
generation and revisit
old concepts in a way that was more
palatable with modern gaming trends
it would have been risky for capcom to
put new players against a sprawling
intricate mansion filled with puzzles
and backtracking
tropes that hadn't been seen in
mainstream aaa games for
decades at this point but after seven's
success those very elements of
backtracking item searching
and exploration came back full force in
resident evil 2 remake
resident evil 2 remake was a no holds
barred representation of what classic
resident evil exploration
and inventory management was but built
into the modern age
and now making a grander more expansive
return
in village lastly we need to talk about
resident evil lore because village
is just bursting at the seams with it in
the final
hours of the game it is revealed that
the main villain mother miranda's
existence
recontextualizes the backstory of the
entire franchise
but no other game has made a similar
contribution other than code veronica
one that i believe helped define
resident evil's absurd and complicated
lore that we know
oh so well today resident evil has grown
to have a soap opera like backstory that
spans hundreds of years
involving nazi-like virologists cloning
australian families and bio-organic
terrorism
and veronica was the first to take it
all and put it front and center
introducing rather theatrical and
eccentric villains
opening the gates beyond just oswell
spencer's madness and introducing edward
ashford a character like spencer fixated
on cloning and biochemical shenanigans
basically code veronica's ashford family
walked so rising before salazar could
run and villages for
lords could soar and in many ways
villages four lords while still an
iteration on seven's baker family
feels closely akin in their theatrics
and over-the-top personas to
code veronica's ashford family
especially in the end of village when we
learn mother miranda's impact on the
entire franchise's lore
which is a lot to impact this is similar
to the impact the ashford family had on
resident evil's lore that interlaced
alongside oswell spencer
veronica had the most deepening effect
on the game's lore at that time
just as village has now causing a ripple
effect
for what's to come the future of the
franchise
now up to this point with each new
installment resident evil has introduced
a new idea some of which were iterated
on for sequels to come
while others were left behind as the
genre shaped and molded
resident evil village on the other hand
has left none of those ideas
behind more than any resident evil
before it
village does the most to embody
everything the franchise has been
up to this point village is a
culmination of all of them
every single element wrapped up and
stapled together
whether it works well that's up to you
to decide but
unabashedly and of course as a resident
of apologist at times
i love it and while it does feel like a
frankenstein's monster
it is an encapsulation of the
franchise's 25 years
and for that reason alone it makes
village one of the most special resident
evil games
today and it does a lot to push the
franchise forward
while doubling down on its past
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
i am storm incarnate
my queen my king
divine beasts with grace replete finally
the twain shall meet
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
the wings of ruin you don't understand
that rather loses
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we can't let you interfere with our
plans
that's the monster red song
you suppose he saw this coming
we won't let you awaken it
[Music]
so you're going to be born huh
over the last 25 years resident evil has
continually changed and evolved as
capcom has tried different mixes of
survival horror and
action gameplay with resident evil 7
capcom swung for the fences with a first
person perspective
and more classic horror focused gameplay
its sequel resident evil village
evolves that idea to make something that
feels very different from its
predecessor
but which is just as engaging though the
perspective and the mechanical
underpinnings are the same
village branches off in its own
direction from re7
capturing some of the things that were
great about that game while resisting
the impulse to retread the same ground
while it's still frightening at points
it takes a less horror driven tack on
the same formula
village continues to evolve resident
evil while maintaining a keen grasp on
some of its core tenants
finding new ways or reviving old ones of
getting under your skin
and ratcheting up the tension where the
hell am i
[Music]
as has been pretty clear for a while now
resident evil village is resident evil 7
through the lens of resident evil 4.
when the latter was released back in
2005
it totally revamped what the franchise
had been up to that point
swapping the earlier game's slower
survival horror focus
for a more fast-paced action approach
trading darkened corridors and jump
scares
for adrenaline-fueled panic village adds
to re7
by taking its cues from the faster
panickier re4
it's again played from a tight in first
person perspective
and it still often focuses on slower
movement and exploration
but village's approach is distinctly
more action-centric
and it's remarkable how much capcom has
managed to push the underlying formula
of its reboot to the series
in such a different direction
village picks up on resident evil 7's
story three years later
again focusing on protagonist ethan
winters after rescuing his wife mia from
the baker house
and subsequently getting saved by
resident evil franchise mainstay chris
redfield
ethan and mia went into hiding with
chris's help moving to europe to restart
their lives
they've since had a daughter but their
lives are offended again when chris and
his team bust into the couple's house
and drag ethan and baby rose off ethan
wakes up sometime later after a car
crash
the two random special forces guys who
were transporting him and rose
are dead ethan wanders through the snowy
woods in search of his missing child
until he hits a ramshackle seemingly
empty village
before long he discovers it's under
siege by what appeared to be
werewolves
it's all extremely reminiscent of the
beginning of resident evil 4
which upended the re formula by dropping
you into a village overrun with enemies
who acted like humans rather than
shambling mindless zombies
the lichens you face wield weapons and
shoot arrows at you
and to avoid getting surrounded you can
run into houses and barricade the doors
with furniture to slow their advances
just like its 2005 inspiration the
opening battle of village taps into a
frightening intensity
of trying to create a defensible
position or take part in a running gun
fight
that you're in serious danger of losing
it's a completely different feeling
from the slow burn dread of re7 but
village's combat can make your heart
pound
just as hard the fact that village feels
like such a turn away from re7
is what works about it as a sequel it
feels like capcom reaching for a new way
to challenge itself
most of the time in village at least on
its standard difficulty
you'll find yourself pretty well
outfitted for whatever you're about to
face the challenge is in using those
resources effectively
and keeping yourself alive village uses
the same movement system as re7
which can feel a little slow and clunky
at times
eden isn't especially agile and even at
a sprint
it can feel like he's barely moving
despite a sense of trudging through mud
village is tuned so that enemies also
approach slowly and cautiously
so dealing with them comes together like
a standoff that has you judging their
moves or hitting their weak points
before they have a chance to get in
close and rip into you
and sometimes you just have to run and
hope you can find a better place to make
your stand
while the controls add tension when
you're surrounded they can be a bit
obtuse making it difficult to avoid
attacks
you're often dodging attacks as a
monster charges you or swings at you
with a huge weapon
you can absorb some damage with the
ability to hold up your hands in a guard
another re7 feature that helps mitigate
the limitations of your movement
but the better strategy is to try to run
around the battlefield and get out of
the way
that usually means sacrificing seeing
what your opponent is doing
since ethan can't step sideways while
looking forward you're constantly just
running and hoping whatever is coming at
you doesn't hit you
it doesn't make these battles
frustrating or add to their difficulty
but it does add a counter-intuitiveness
to combat that can take you out of the
moment
bullets are easy to come by and if
you're short you can craft more from
materials you find
or purchase them from the duke a
traveling merchant all that stuff you're
carrying around has to go somewhere
so village brings back the inventory
management system of re4
you have a suitcase full of weapons ammo
and health items with each taking up
space on a grid
you can move items around to make sure
they all fit in your case tetris style
and purchase bigger cases from the duke
so you can bring more stuff
the system is most interesting when it
starts making you wonder if you should
sell off old guns or toss less useful
items in favor
of things like extra ammo mercifully
crafting items don't count against your
inventory space
so you're free to make bullets and
health items on the fly on standard
difficulty it was never a big concern
but you do have to start thinking about
keeping space open as you explore in
case you find something essential
though village has far more variety of
enemies to fight than re7
it's not all shooting with a lot of
varied pacing and new challenges
throughout
there are four different areas to unlock
as you progress through the story
each headed by one of the four lords the
scary monster people who dominate the
village
and the area around it after the opening
village the first is the castle run by
lady dimitresk
where there's a lot less shooting to be
done you'll occasionally face enemies
you have to gun down
but much more time in the castle is
spent navigating its tight corridors
as you're hunted by the vampire
demotrask and her daughters
you can't kill the vampires with your
conventional weapons so you have to run
if you're found
the entire level is spent exploring the
castle looking for the items you need to
advance through the area
while listening for dematresque's
clumping footsteps and trying to keep
away from her
even in this first new area village is
mixing and remixing its experience
with different horror ideas you're not
just shotgunning a ton of enemies
you're also engaging in stealth more
akin to what navigating the baker house
was like in re7
and later portions of the game throw
different obstacles into your path
there are areas that are full of puzzles
that are reminiscent of the mansion of
resident evil
or the police station of re2 there are
sections where you hear frightfully
powerful enemies in the distance you
know you'll have to fight
and there are points that show village
can still hone in on some of the intense
frights that made re7
so remarkable suffice to say that
village is great at maintaining an
atmosphere of unease
as you head around each new corner sure
you have plenty of weapons
but can you handle what you're about to
face will they even work against the
next creature you encounter
there's an excellent balance between
providing lots of action
and maintaining that dread village
encourages its own kind of fear
and it hits you with a few great re7
like set pieces
to ratchet up the tension when you least
expect it no two sections of village
are quite the same each draws on
different aspects of
past resident evil games and combines
them with that underlying re7 feel
to create something that's both new and
nostalgic
it's impressive how the game can change
to be a little different
again and again throughout its run time
mixing in other ideas from the franchise
to make each section
fun intense and naturally frightening
in its own way the exception to that is
the last hour of the game
where things take a weird over-the-top
turn in the run-up to village's final
moments
the action gets turned up even higher it
seems like a needless digression
where village draws on the worst
action-heavy portions of resident evil 6
losing track of what made you grit your
teeth and clench your fists
and exchanging it for something more
akin to shooters like call of duty this
same moment highlights some of the
inconsistency
in village's story though the game's
imagery
recalls the umbrella logo from past
games village's connection to the rest
of the franchise
feels a bit tacked on the same is true
of chris redfield
whose presence in the story feels like
an afterthought ethan's interactions
with the four lords and the mystery of
the village
is more fun and interesting since the
antagonists come off as petty
flawed and human they don't particularly
like each other
but are all eager to torture and maim
you anyway
and their interactions with ethan and
each other add dimension to their
characters
likens and gentlemen
we thank you and now that the games
begin
village is a spooky romp with fun
villains but it's just a shame that more
time wasn't devoted to the hanging story
threads of re7
or the franchise at large thankfully
that digression doesn't last long
meanwhile the elements about combat that
are fun are transplanted into the
fast-paced arcade mode
the mercenaries the mode takes the
combat of the village
slaps a timer on it and focuses it on
scoring points
the mercenaries is a fun side activity
in its own right
always daring you to get a higher score
by balancing taking down as many enemies
as you can
and trying to complete one of its given
levels as fast as you can
it demonstrates how tight the combat and
village can be
although at times it can be held back a
bit by the slow underwater feeling of
movement around the battlefield
resident evil 7 was an excellent return
to the horror roots of the franchise
with some coming new ideas similarly
village is an intelligent reimagination
of the best action elements of resident
evil
though it captures some of the same
things that made re7
such a breath of fresh air village uses
new takes on the ideas of the past
to evolve into its own unique creature
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
please we have to get on that boat
abuela
what the hell i'm gonna do with baseball
cards do you have any idea what these
are worth
let us do oh yeah marco
always making new friends donny you're
late where's alejo
he gave up his ticket for his family
[ __ ] alexander
is not going anywhere anymore come on
let them on
good man get out of the box and god
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry about it chamaco here that's
all i've got
this isn't right danny we should be
fighting up
running to the young keys alejo gave you
a [ __ ] gift
lyra we survive same as the orphanage
same as the academy
[Music]
please no no this is
[Music]
[Music]
before he was el presidente
me papa love to fish we would go out on
a boat
just like this and we would catch the
fish
and then release them he would say
it's not always about your stomach me oh
it's about the challenge
except when he got a big fat
juicy marlin he was too proud
to let that fish go see no no
you have eyes and yellow you are fine
i have caught a very big fish today
have a night diego
diego
no way
i have caught you mijo now it's time to
bring you home
i don't want this anymore papa we have
no choice
let them go they can work make viviro
truth
or lies truth
they could be good workers
they could help rebuild paradise
but if you wanted them to live
you would have never set foot on this
[ __ ] boat
13 years old and diego has
such compassion for his people
these fish
we will catch a release
resident evil has had many faces and
even the lack
of one over its 25 years of existence
i've seen this franchise
transform mold and redefine itself over
and over and over again being everything
from a teeth grinding horror madhouse to
a co-op
over the top hollywood action romp too
most recently
an absolute thirst trap wow i've seen
the franchise take detours into
different
genres set pieces and concepts some more
successful than
others and everything the franchise has
attempted
accomplished and even failed at is in
resident evil village one way or another
from a genre defining breakthrough to
some of the more
debatable entries resident evil village
is the most
resident evil game of them all
let me break this down the foundation of
resident evil village
lies on well the actual village it's a
sprawling maze-like
area with dead ends locked doors and
obtuse paths
but as the game progresses it connects
to the other areas unraveling new ones
to be discovered rewarding the player
with keys and items that compel them
to backtrack and re-explore it this was
a trope defined by the franchise's very
first entry back in 1996
and it was a revolution for horror games
and the first to define a genre
the survival horror genre it took
elements from adventure games with
exploration
backtracking and item-based puzzles and
then apply to survival to it
by giving the player very limited
resources and enemies that soaked up
that precious
precious ammunition it was a slow paced
slog through a maze-like environment of
narrow halls
forcing the player to make life or death
choices around every corner of the
confusingly designed oswell spencer
mansion this is a characteristic that
would come and go through the franchise
with backtracking
puzzles being last seen most prominently
in the fourth entry in the series code
veronica back in 2000
it did make its grand return in resident
evil 7 but
even then the exploration was pale in
comparison to 1
2 and veronica that is until
resident evil village the village opens
and unravels similarly to the original
oswell mansion from one and the raccoon
city police department from
two or even more accurately like code
veronica's european gothic
palace and victorian mansion especially
considering its similar aesthetic to
lady dimitrisk's castle
in resident evil village speaking of big
lady dean let's talk about being chased
as you navigate the halls of
demotresque's castle she
and her daughters will stalk and follow
you as you desperately try to find
keys and items to unlock and open other
areas
this iconic and terrifying
characteristic comes straight from
resident evil 3
nemesis resident evil 3 threw a wrench
in the tropes that one and two had
created
trading off the slow pacing for urgency
and paranoia that big baddie nemesis
could bust through at any moment
a towering invincible foe that stalks
you constantly
ramping up the pressure when you least
expect it
like many ideas of the resident evil
franchise the mechanic of constantly
being pursued wouldn't make a return
until again resident evil 7 with jack
baker
but it wasn't fully mastered until
resident evil 2 remake with mr x
the resident evil 2 remake took jack
baker's stalking mechanic
and launched it to the nth degree with
mr x making him a towering
silent goon that slammed through
anything to get you
mr x did make an appearance in the og
resident evil 2 during the b
scenario but not to the same degree as
nemesis and capcom
but at full force in the remake lady
democresque is the embodiment of both
jack baker and
mr x a family woman just looking after
her own while also being an
intimidatingly huge individual big
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up real hard energy
while you're traversing villages many
different environments there'll be
treasure to find animals to hunt
and this jolly old fella to find solace
in as you sell items upgrade weapons
and buy new ones that you can organize
in your tetris-like inventory
all of this is thanks to resident evil
4. residual 4 ripped the franchise away
from its fixed camera angles expanded
your arsenal and turn the harrowing odds
against one zombie up to 11
favoring overwhelming stress over pure
horror
a near copy of village's encounters with
a lichens
especially in its opening sequence when
you're overwhelmingly outnumbered and
have to barricade yourself into a house
four introduce the tetris-like inventory
case the treasure hunting
currency and a merchant to sell items
with most of these mechanics are
defining a four's identity
and interestingly never appear in the
franchise again
that is until now with village some of
four's influences on village may not be
as apparent
as others however probably the most
notorious area
in village is house beneviento which not
only features an adorable baby but
these terrifying ghost dolls which
aren't
entirely new to the franchise while 4
was in development it had gone through
several different prototypes until
coming to what it is today
one internal version of the game was
known as the hallucination version
in this prototype build there was a room
known simply as
the doll room where leon kennedy would
fight against these pesky
19th century porcelain dolls while this
didn't end up making the cut for
resident evil 4 it was revived and
cemented in village
meaning full force into the supernatural
elements that resident evil only toyed
with
behind the curtains and it gets to be a
little nice wink and nod to us resident
evil nerds who caught it
and with no reasonable transition let's
talk about chris redfield
an overarching plot device in resident
evil village is chris
who swoops into the opening moments of
the game killing ethan's wife and
kidnapping his baby
chris is among the longest standing
characters in the franchise first
appearing in resident evil 1 alongside
jill valentine
but the game to have the most defining
impact on his character shaping him into
the bulky military head that
he is now is resident evil 5. taking him
from the soft face boy from resident
evil 1 and code veronica and
establishing
his military attitude and muscles
mechanically village didn't really take
that much from the co-op focused five
aside from carrying the weight of
redfield's pecs but when resident evil 6
rolled around it had completely launched
the franchise into full-blown hollywood
antics with over-the-top action
and a sprawling cast of characters that
make even a soap opera jealous
village captures six essence at its
finest near the closing hours
when we step into the shoes of chris
tricep redfield and go
buck wild on waves of lichens all call
of duty style
all of which comes to a close with a
mushroom cloud
while resident evil 6 is notoriously
divisive among fans for being a
full-on hollywood action game it seems
that village couldn't help itself from
going
a little off the rails once again but
hey at least it didn't have a zombie
t-rex monster thing
right
obviously resident evil village carried
a lot over from its predecessor resident
evil
7. while 7 softly returned to its
exploration and backtracking roots
its biggest contribution to the
franchise was its change to a first
person perspective
resident evil 7 was the first true
reimagining the franchise had seen in a
decade since resident
iv but this time around making it first
person leaning all
in on horror and lightly attempting to
revisit the franchise's dna with an
emphasis on tight spaces exploration and
arbitrary locked doors
this is something that village doubles
down on more interesting is how the game
is structured
showcasing resident evil 7's antagonists
as a family
front and center with each foe having
their own distinct area to explore and
maneuver through
a prominent trait carried over into
village's narrative structure when being
introduced to
the four lords resident evil 7 felt like
an attempt to reposition the franchise
with a new generation and revisit
old concepts in a way that was more
palatable with modern gaming trends
it would have been risky for capcom to
put new players against a sprawling
intricate mansion filled with puzzles
and backtracking
tropes that hadn't been seen in
mainstream aaa games for
decades at this point but after seven's
success those very elements of
backtracking item searching
and exploration came back full force in
resident evil 2 remake
resident evil 2 remake was a no holds
barred representation of what classic
resident evil exploration and
inventory management was but built into
the modern age
and now making a grander more expansive
return
in village lastly we need to talk about
resident evil lore because village
is just bursting at the seams with it in
the final
hours of the game it is revealed that
the main villain mother miranda's
existence
recontextualizes the backstory of the
entire franchise
but no other game has made a similar
contribution other than code veronica
one that i believe helped define
resident evil's absurd and complicated
lore that we know
oh so well today resident evil has grown
to have a soap opera like backstory that
spans hundreds of years
involving nazi-like virologists cloning
australian families and bio-organic
terrorism and veronica
was the first to take it all and put it
front and center
introducing rather theatrical and
eccentric villains
opening the gates beyond just oswell
spencer's madness and introducing edward
ashford a character like spencer fixated
on cloning and biochemical shenanigans
basically code veronica's ashford family
walks on resume 4
salazar could run and villages for lords
could soar
and in many ways village's four lords
while still an iteration on seven's
baker family
feels closely akin in their theatrics
and over-the-top personas to
code veronica's ashford family
especially in the end of village when we
learn mother miranda's impact on the
entire franchise's lore
which is a lot to impact this is similar
to the impact the ashford family had on
resident evil's lore that interlaced
alongside oswell spencer
veronica had the most deepening effect
on the game's lore at that time
just as village has now causing a ripple
effect
for what's to come the future of the
franchise
now up to this point with each new
installment resident evil has introduced
a new idea
some of which were iterated on for
sequels to come
while others were left behind as the
genre shaped and molded
resident evil village on the other hand
has left none of those ideas
behind more than any resident evil
before it
village does the most to embody
everything the franchise has been
up to this point village is a
culmination of all of them
every single element wrapped up and
stapled together
whether it works well that's up to you
to decide
but unabashedly and of course as a
residual apologist at times
i love it and while it does feel like a
frankenstein's monster
it is an encapsulation of the
franchise's 25 years
and for that reason alone it makes
village one of the most special resident
evil games
today and it does a lot to push the
franchise forward
while doubling down on its past
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i am storm incarnate
my queen my king
divine beasts with grace replete finally
the twain shall meet
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
the wings of ruin you don't understand
that rather loses
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can't let you interfere with our
plans
that's the monster red song
you suppose he saw this coming
we won't let you awaken it
[Music]
so you're going to be born huh
over the last 25 years resident evil has
continually changed and evolved as
capcom has tried different mixes of
survival horror and
action gameplay with resident evil 7
capcom swung for the fences
with a first-person perspective and more
classic horror-focused gameplay
its sequel resident evil village evolves
that idea to make something that feels
very different from its predecessor but
which is just as engaging
though the perspective and the
mechanical underpinnings are the same
village branches off in its own
direction from re7
capturing some of the things that were
great about that game while resisting
the impulse to retread the same ground
while it's still frightening at points
it takes a less horror driven tack on
the same formula
village continues to evolve resident
evil while maintaining a keen grasp on
some of its core tenants
finding new ways or reviving old ones of
getting under your skin
and ratcheting up the tension where the
hell am i
[Music]
as has been pretty clear for a while now
resident evil village is resident evil 7
through the lens of resident evil 4.
when the latter was released back in
2005
it totally revamped what the franchise
had been up to that point
swapping the earlier game slower
survival horror focus
for a more fast-paced action approach
trading darkened corridors and jump
scares
for adrenaline-fueled panic village adds
to re7
by taking its cues from the faster
panickier re4
it's again played from a tight closed-in
first-person perspective
and it still often focuses on slower
movement and exploration
but village's approach is distinctly
more action-centric
and it's remarkable how much capcom has
managed to push the underlying formula
of its reboot to the series in such a
different direction
village picks up on resident evil 7's
story three years later
again focusing on protagonist ethan
winters after rescuing his wife mia from
the baker house
and subsequently getting saved by
resident evil franchise mainstay chris
redfield
ethan and mia went into hiding with
chris's help moving to europe to restart
their lives
they've since had a daughter but their
lives are offended again when chris and
his team
bust into the couple's house and drag
ethan and baby rose off
ethan wakes up sometime later after a
car crash the two random special forces
guys who were transporting him and rose
are dead ethan wanders through the snowy
woods in search of his missing child
until he hits a ramshackle seemingly
empty village
before long he discovers it's under
siege by what appeared to be
werewolves
it's all extremely reminiscent of the
beginning of resident evil 4
which upended the re formula by dropping
you into a village overrun with enemies
who acted like humans rather than
shambling mindless zombies
the lichens you face wield weapons and
shoot arrows at you
and to avoid getting surrounded you can
run into houses and barricade the doors
with furniture to slow their advances
just like its 2005 inspiration the
opening battle of village taps into a
frightening intensity
of trying to create a defensible
position or take part in a running
gunfight
that you're in serious danger of losing
it's a completely different feeling
from the slow-burned dread of re7 but
village's combat can make your heart
pound
just as hard the fact that village feels
like such a turn away from re7
is what works about it as a sequel it
feels like capcom reaching for a new way
to challenge itself
most of the time in village at least on
its standard difficulty
you'll find yourself pretty well
outfitted for whatever you're about to
face
the challenge is in using those
resources effectively and keeping
yourself alive
village uses the same movement system as
re7 which can feel a little slow and
clunky at times
eden isn't especially agile and even at
a sprint
it can feel like he's barely moving
despite a sense of trudging through mud
village is tuned so that enemies also
approach slowly and cautiously
so dealing with them comes together like
a standoff that has you judging their
moves
or hitting their weak points before they
have a chance to get in close and rip
into you
and sometimes you just have to run and
hope you can find a better place to make
your stand
while the controls add tension when
you're surrounded they can be a bit
obtuse making it difficult to avoid
attacks
you're often dodging attacks as a
monster charges you or swings at you
with a huge weapon
you can absorb some damage with the
ability to hold up your hands in a guard
another re7 feature that helps mitigate
the limitations of your movement
but the better strategy is to try to run
around the battlefield and get out of
the way
that usually means sacrificing seeing
what your opponent is doing
since ethan can't step sideways while
looking forward you're constantly just
running and hoping whatever is coming at
you doesn't hit you
it doesn't make these battles
frustrating or add to their difficulty
but it does add a counter-intuitiveness
to combat that can take you out of the
moment
bullets are easy to come by and if
you're short you can craft more from
materials you find
or purchase them from the duke a
traveling merchant all that stuff you're
carrying around has to go somewhere
so village brings back the inventory
management system of re4
you have a suitcase full of weapons ammo
and health items with each taking up
space
on a grid you can move items around to
make sure they all fit in your case
tetris style and purchase bigger cases
from the duke so you can bring more
stuff
the system is most interesting when it
starts making you wonder if you should
sell off old guns or toss less useful
items in favor of things like extra ammo
mercifully crafting items don't count
against your inventory space
so you're free to make bullets and
health items on the fly on standard
difficulty it was never a big concern
but you do have to start thinking about
keeping space open as you explore in
case you find something essential
though village has far more variety of
enemies to fight than re7
it's not all shooting with a lot of
varied pacing and new challenges
throughout
there are four different areas to unlock
as you progress through the story
each headed by one of the four lords the
scary monster people who dominate the
village
and the area around it after the opening
village the first is the castle run by
lady dimitresk
where there's a lot less shooting to be
done you'll occasionally face enemies
you have to gun down
but much more time in the castle is
spent navigating its tight corridors
as you're hunted by the vampire
demotrask and her daughters
you can't kill the vampires with your
conventional weapons so you have to run
if you're found
the entire level is spent exploring the
castle looking for the items you need to
advance through the area
while listening for dematresque's
clumping footsteps and trying to keep
away from her
even in this first new area village is
mixing and remixing its experience
with different horror ideas you're not
just shotgunning a ton of enemies
you're also engaging in stealth more
akin to what navigating the baker house
was like in re7
and later portions of the game throw
different obstacles into your path
there are areas that are full of puzzles
that are reminiscent of the mansion of
resident evil
or the police station of re2 there are
sections where you hear frightfully
powerful enemies in the distance you
know you'll have to fight
and there are points that show village
can still hone in on some of the intense
frights that made re7
so remarkable suffice to say that
village is great at maintaining an
atmosphere of unease
as you head around each new corner sure
you have plenty of weapons
but can you handle what you're about to
face will they even work against the
next creature you encounter
there's an excellent balance between
providing lots of action
and maintaining that dread village
encourages its own kind of fear
and it hits you with a few great re7
like set pieces
to ratchet up the tension when you least
expect it no two sections of village
are quite the same each draws on
different aspects of
past resident evil games and combines
them with that underlying
re7 feel to create something that's both
new
and nostalgic it's impressive how the
game can change
to be a little different again and again
throughout its run time
mixing in other ideas from the franchise
to make each section
fun intense and naturally frightening
in its own way the exception to that is
the last hour of the game
where things take a weird over-the-top
turn in the run-up to villages final
moments
the action gets turned up even higher it
seems like a needless digression
where village draws on the worst
action-heavy portions of resident evil 6
losing track of what made you grit your
teeth and clench your fists
and exchanging it for something more
akin to shooters like call of duty
this same moment highlights some of the
inconsistency
in village's story though the game's
imagery
recalls the umbrella logo from past
games village's connection to the rest
of the franchise
feels a bit tacked on the same is true
of chris redfield
whose presence in the story feels like
an afterthought ethan's interactions
with the four lords and the mystery of
the village
is more fun and interesting since the
antagonists come off as petty
flawed and human they don't particularly
like each other
but are all eager to torture and maim
you anyway
and their interactions with ethan and
each other add dimension to their
characters
likens and gentlemen
we thank you for waiting and now let the
games begin
village is a spooky romp with fun
villains but it's just a shame that more
time wasn't devoted to the hanging story
threads of re7
or the franchise at large thankfully
that digression doesn't last long
meanwhile the elements about combat that
are fun are transplanted
into the fast-paced arcade mode the
mercenaries
the mode takes the combat of the village
slaps a timer on it
and focuses it on scoring points the
mercenaries is a fun side activity in
its own right
always daring you to get a higher score
by balancing taking down as many enemies
as you can
and trying to complete one of its given
levels as fast as you can
it demonstrates how tight the combat and
village can be
although at times it can be held back a
bit by the slow underwater feeling of
movement around the battlefield
resident evil 7 was an excellent return
to the horror roots of the franchise
with some coming new ideas similarly
village is an intelligent reimagination
of the best action elements of resident
evil
though it captures some of the same
things that made re7
such a breath of fresh air village uses
new takes on the ideas of the past
to evolve into its own unique creature
resident evil has had many faces and
even the lack of one
over its 25 years of existence i've seen
this franchise
transform mold and redefine itself over
and over and over again being everything
from a teeth grinding horror madhouse to
a co-op
over the top hollywood action romp to
most recently
an absolute thirst trap wow i've seen
the franchise take detours into
different
genres set pieces and concepts some more
successful than
others and everything the franchise has
attempted
accomplished and even failed at is in
resident evil village one way or another
from a genre defining breakthrough to
some of the more
debatable entries resident evil village
is the
most resident evil game of them all
let me break this down the foundation of
resident evil village
lies on well the actual village it's a
sprawling maze-like area with dead ends
locked doors and obtuse paths
but as the game progresses it connects
to the other areas unraveling new ones
to be discovered
rewarding the player with keys and items
that compel them
to backtrack and re-explore it this was
a trope defined by the franchise's very
first
entry back in 1996 and it was a
revolution for horror games
and the first to define a genre the
survival horror genre
it took elements from adventure games
with exploration backtracking
and item-based puzzles and then apply to
survival to it
by giving the player very limited
resources and enemies that soaked up
that precious
precious ammunition it was a slow paced
slog through a maze-like environment of
narrow hulls
forcing the player to make life or death
choices around
every corner of the confusingly designed
oswell
spencer mansion this is a characteristic
that would come and go through the
franchise with backtracking and puzzles
being last seen most prominently
in the fourth entry in the series code
veronica back in 2000.
it did make its grand return in resident
evil 7 but
even then the exploration was pale in
comparison to 1
2 in veronica that is until
resident evil village the village opens
and unravels similarly to the original
oswell mansion from one and the raccoon
city police department
from 2 or even more accurately like code
veronica's european gothic
palace and victorian mansion especially
considering its similar aesthetic to
lady dimitrisk's castle
in resident evil village speaking of big
lady d let's talk about being
chased as you navigate the halls of
demotresque's castle
she and her daughters will stalk and
follow you as you desperately try to
find
keys and items to unlock at open other
areas
this iconic and terrifying
characteristic comes straight from
resident evil 3
nemesis resident evil 3 threw a wrench
in the tropes that one and two had
created trading off the slow pacing for
urgency and paranoia that big baddie
nemesis could bust through at any moment
a towering invincible foe that stalks
you constantly
ramping up the pressure when you least
expect it
like many ideas of the resident evil
franchise the mechanic of constantly
being pursued wouldn't make a return
until
again resident evil 7 with jack baker
but it wasn't fully mastered until
resident evil 2 remake with mr
x the resident evil 2 remake took jack
baker's stalking mechanic and launched
it to the nth degree with mr x
making him a towering silent goon that
slammed through
anything to get you mr x did make an
appearance in the og resident evil 2
during the b
scenario but not to the same degree as
nemesis and capcom
but at full force in the remake lady
dimitrisk is the embodiment
of both jack baker and mr x a family
woman just looking after her own while
also being an intimidatingly huge
individual big i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
real hard
energy while you're traversing villages
many different environments there'll be
treasure to find
animals to hunt and this jolly old fella
to find solace in as you sell items
upgrade weapons and buy new ones that
you can organize in your tetris-like
inventory
all of this is thanks to resident evil
4. residual 4 ripped the franchise away
from its fixed camera angles expanded
your arsenal and turned the harrowing
odds against one zombie up to 11
favoring overwhelming stress over pure
horror
a near copy of village's encounters with
a lichens
especially in its opening sequence when
you're overwhelmingly outnumbered and
have to barricade yourself into a house
four introduce the tetris-like inventory
case the treasure hunting
currency and a merchant to sell items
with most of these mechanics are
defining a four's identity
and interestingly never appeared in the
franchise again
that is until now with village some of
four's influences on village may not be
as apparent as others however
probably the most notorious area in
village is house beneviento which not
only features an adorable baby but
these terrifying ghost dolls which
aren't entirely new
to the franchise while four was in
development it had gone through several
different prototypes until coming to
what it is today
one internal version of the game was
known as the hallucination version
in this prototype build there was a room
known simply as
the doll room where leon kennedy would
fight against these pesky
19th century porcelain dolls while this
didn't end up making the cut for
resident evil 4
it was revived and cemented in village
leaning full force
into the supernatural elements that
resident evil only toyed with behind the
curtains
and it gets to be a little nice wink and
nod to us resident evil nerds who caught
it
and with no reasonable transition let's
talk about chris redfield
an overarching plot device in resident
village is chris who swoops into the
opening moments of the game
killing ethan's wife and kidnapping his
baby chris is among the longest standing
characters in the franchise first
appearing in resident evil 1 alongside
jill valentine
but the game to have the most defining
impact on his character
shaping him into the bulky military head
that he is now
is resident evil 5. taking him from the
soft-faced boy from resident evil 1 and
code veronica and establishing
his military attitude and muscles
mechanically village didn't really take
that much from the co-op focused five
aside from carrying the weight of
redfield's pecks but when resident evil
6 rolled around it had completely
launched the franchise into full-blown
hollywood antics with over-the-top
action
and a sprawling cast of characters that
make even a soap opera jealous
village captures six essence at its
finest near the closing hours when we
step into the shoes of chris tricep
redfield and go
buck wild on waves of likens all call of
duty style
all of which comes to a close with a
mushroom cloud
while resident evil 6 is notoriously
divisive among fans for being a
full-on hollywood action game it seems
that village couldn't help itself from
going
a little off the rails once again but
hey at least it didn't have a zombie
t-rex monster thing right
obviously resident evil village carried
a lot over from its predecessor resident
evil 7
while seven softly returned to its
exploration and backtracking roots
its biggest contribution to the
franchise was its change to a first
person perspective
resident evil 7 was the first true
reimagining the franchise had seen in a
decade since resident evil 4
but this time around making it first
person leaning all in on horror
and lightly attempting to revisit the
franchise's dna with an
emphasis on tight spaces exploration and
arbitrary locked doors
this is something that village doubles
down on more interesting is how the game
is structured
showcasing resident evil 7's antagonists
as a family
front and center with each foe having
their own distinct area to explore and
maneuver through
a prominent trait carried over into
village's narrative structure when being
introduced to
the four lords resident evil 7 felt like
an attempt to reposition the franchise
with a new generation and revisit
old concepts in a way that was more
palatable with modern gaming trends
it would have been risky for capcom to
put new players against a sprawling
intricate
mansion filled with puzzles and
backtracking tropes that hadn't been
seen in mainstream
aaa games for decades at this point but
after 7's success
those very elements of backtracking item
searching and exploration came back full
force in resident evil 2 remake resident
evil 2 remake was a no holds barred
representation of what classic resident
evil exploration
and inventory management was but built
into the modern age
and now making a grander more expansive
return
in village lastly we need to talk about
resident evil lore because village
is just bursting at the seams with it in
the final hours of the game it is
revealed that the main villain mother
miranda's existence
recontextualizes the backstory of the
entire franchise
but no other game has made a similar
contribution other than code veronica
one that i believe helped define
resident evil's absurd and complicated
lore that we know
oh so well today resident evil has grown
to have a soap opera like backstory that
spans hundreds of years
involving nazi-like virologists cloning
australian families and bio-organic
terrorism
and veronica was the first to take it
all and put it
front and center introducing rather
theatrical and eccentric villains
opening the gates beyond just oswell
spencer's madness and introducing
edward ashford a character like spencer
fixated on cloning and biochemical
shenanigans
basically code veronica's ashford family
walk so resume 4
salazar could run and villages for lords
could soar
and in many ways villages 4 lords while
still an iteration on seven's baker
family
feels closely akin in their theatrics
and over-the-top personas to
code veronica's ashford family
especially in the end of village when we
learn mother miranda's impact on the
entire franchise's lore
which is a lot to impact this is similar
to the impact the ashford family had on
resident evil's lore that interlaced
alongside
oswell spencer veronica had the most
deepening effect on the game's lore at
that time just as village
has now causing a ripple effect for
what's to come the future of the
franchise
now up to this point with each new
installment resident evil has introduced
a new idea
some of which were iterated on for
sequels to come
while others were left behind as the
genre shaped and molded
resident evil village on the other hand
has left none of those ideas
behind more than any resident evil
before it
village does the most to embody
everything the franchise
has been up to this point village is a
culmination of all of them
every single element wrapped up and
stapled together whether it works well
that's up to you to decide but
unabashedly
and of course as a resident evil
apologist at times i love it
and while it does feel like a
frankenstein's monster
it is an encapsulation of the
franchise's 25 years
and for that reason alone it makes
village one of the most special resident
evil games
today and it does a lot to push the
franchise forward
while doubling down on its past
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
i am storm incarnate
[Music]
my queen my king
shall meet
[Music]
foreign
no
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
the wings of ruin you don't
understand that rapper loses
[Music]
we can't let you interfere with our
plans
that's the monster redzone
you suppose he saw this coming
[Music]
we won't let you awaken it
so you're going to be born huh
over the last 25 years resident evil has
continually changed and evolved as
capcom has tried different mixes of
survival horror and action gameplay
with resident evil 7 capcom swung for
the fences with a first-person
perspective
and more classic horror focused gameplay
its sequel resident evil village
evolves that idea to make something that
feels very different from its
predecessor
but which is just as engaging though the
perspective and the mechanical
underpinnings are the same
village branches off in its own
direction from re7
capturing some of the things that were
great about that game while resisting
the impulse to retread the same ground
while it's still frightening at points
it takes a less horror-driven tack on
the same formula
village continues to evolve resident
evil while maintaining a keen grasp on
some of its core tenants
finding new ways or reviving old ones of
getting under your skin
and ratcheting up the tension where the
hell am i
[Music]
as has been pretty clear for a while now
resident evil village is resident evil 7
through the lens of resident evil 4.
when the latter was released back in
2005
it totally revamped what the franchise
had been up to that point
swapping the earlier game slower
survival horror focus
for a more fast-paced action approach
trading darkened corridors and jump
scares
for adrenaline-fueled panic village adds
to re7
by taking its cues from the faster
panickier re4
it's again played from a tight closed-in
first-person perspective
and it still often focuses on slower
movement and exploration
but village's approach is distinctly
more action-centric
and it's remarkable how much capcom has
managed to push the underlying formula
of its reboot to the series
in such a different direction
village picks up on resident evil 7's
story three years later
again focusing on protagonist ethan
winters after rescuing his wife mia from
the baker house
and subsequently getting saved by
resident evil franchise mainstay
chris revfield ethan and mia went into
hiding with chris's help
moving to europe to restart their lives
they've since had a daughter
but their lives are offended again when
chris and his team bust into the
couple's house
and drag ethan and baby rose off ethan
wakes up sometime later after a car
crash
the two random special forces guys who
were transporting him and rose
are dead ethan wanders through the snowy
woods in search of his missing child
until he hits a ramshackle seemingly
empty village
before long he discovers it's under
siege by what appeared to be
werewolves
it's all extremely reminiscent of the
beginning of resident evil 4
which upended the re formula by dropping
you into a village overrun with enemies
who acted like humans rather than
shambling mindless zombies
the lichens you face wield weapons and
shoot arrows at you
and to avoid getting surrounded you can
run into houses and barricade the doors
with furniture to slow their advances
just like its 2005 inspiration the
opening battle of village taps into a
frightening intensity of trying to
create a defensible position
or take part in a running gunfight that
you're in serious danger of losing
it's a completely different feeling from
the slow burn dread of re7
but village's combat can make your heart
pound just as hard
the fact that village feels like such a
turn away from re7
is what works about it as a sequel it
feels like capcom reaching for a new way
to challenge itself
most of the time in village at least on
its standard difficulty
you'll find yourself pretty well
outfitted for whatever you're about to
face
the challenges in using those resources
effectively and keeping yourself alive
village uses the same movement system as
re7 which can feel a little slow and
clunky at times
eden isn't especially agile and even at
a sprint
it can feel like he's barely moving
despite a sense of trudging through mud
village is tuned so that enemies also
approach slowly and cautiously
so dealing with them comes together like
a standoff that has you judging their
moves
or hitting their weak points before they
have a chance to get in close and rip
into you and sometimes you just have to
run and hope you can find a better place
to make your stand
while the controls add tension when
you're surrounded they can be a bit
obtuse making it difficult to avoid
attacks
you're often dodging attacks as a
monster charges you or swings at you
with a huge weapon
you can absorb some damage with the
ability to hold up your hands in a guard
another re7 feature that helps mitigate
the limitations of your movement
but the better strategy is to try to run
around the battlefield and get out of
the way
that usually means sacrificing seeing
what your opponent
is doing since ethan can't step sideways
while looking forward
you're constantly just running and
hoping whatever is coming at you
doesn't hit you it doesn't make these
battles frustrating or add to their
difficulty
but it does add a counter-intuitiveness
to combat that can take you out of the
moment
bullets are easy to come by and if
you're short you can craft more from
materials you find
or purchase them from the duke a
traveling merchant all that stuff you're
carrying around has to go somewhere
so village brings back the inventory
management system of re4
you have a suitcase full of weapons ammo
and health items with each taking up
space on a grid
you can move items around to make sure
they all fit in your case tetris style
and purchase bigger cases from the duke
so you can bring more stuff
the system is most interesting when it
starts making you wonder if you should
sell off old guns or toss less useful
items
in favor of things like extra ammo
mercifully
crafting items don't count against your
inventory space so you're free to make
bullets and health items on the fly
on standard difficulty it was never a
big concern but you do have to start
thinking about keeping space open as you
explore in case you find something
essential though village has
far more variety of enemies to fight
than re7
it's not all shooting with a lot of
varied pacing and new challenges
throughout
there are four different areas to unlock
as you progress through the story
each headed by one of the four lords the
scary monster people who dominate the
village
and the area around it after the opening
village the first is the castle run by
lady dimitresk
where there's a lot less shooting to be
done you'll occasionally face enemies
you have to gun down
but much more time in the castle is
spent navigating its tight corridors
as you're hunted by the vampire
demotrask and her daughters
you can't kill the vampires with your
conventional weapons so you have to run
if you're found
the entire level is spent exploring the
castle looking for the items you need to
advance through the area
while listening for diematresque's
clumping footsteps and trying to keep
away from her
even in this first new area village is
mixing and remixing
its experience with different horror
ideas you're not just shotgunning a ton
of enemies
you're also engaging in stealth more
akin to what navigating the baker house
was like in re7
and later portions of the game throw
different obstacles into your path there
are areas that are full of puzzles that
are reminiscent of the mansion of
resident evil
or the police station of re2 there are
sections where you hear frightfully
powerful enemies in the distance you
know you'll have to fight
and there are points that show village
can still hone in on some of the intense
frights that made
re7 so remarkable suffice to say
that village is great at maintaining an
atmosphere of unease
as you head around each new corner sure
you have plenty of weapons
but can you handle what you're about to
face will they even work against the
next creature you encounter
there's an excellent balance between
providing lots of action
and maintaining that dread village
encourages its own kind of fear
and hits you with a few great re7 like
set pieces
to ratchet up the tension when you least
expect it no two sections of village are
quite the same
each draws on different aspects of past
resident evil games and combines them
with that underlying
re7 feel to create something that's both
new and nostalgic
it's impressive how the game can change
to be a little different
again and again throughout its run time
mixing in other ideas from the franchise
to make each section
fun intense and naturally frightening in
its own way
the exception to that is the last hour
of the game where things take a weird
over-the-top turn in the run-up to
village's final moments
the action gets turned up even higher it
seems like a needless digression
where village draws on the worst
action-heavy portions of resident evil 6
losing track of what made you grit your
teeth and clench your fists
and exchanging it for something more
akin to shooters like call of duty
this same moment highlights some of the
inconsistency in village's story
though the game's imagery recalls the
umbrella logo from past games
village's connection to the rest of the
franchise feels a bit tacked on
the same is true of chris redfield whose
presence in the story
feels like an afterthought ethan's
interactions with the four lords and the
mystery of the village
is more fun and interesting since the
antagonists come off as petty
flawed and human they don't particularly
like each other
but are all eager to torture and maim
you anyway
and their interactions with ethan and
each other add dimension to their
characters
likens and gentlemen
we thank you and now let the games begin
village is a spooky romp with fun
villains but it's just a shame that more
time wasn't devoted to the hanging story
threads of re7
or the franchise at large thankfully
that digression doesn't last
long meanwhile the elements about combat
that are fun
are transplanted into the fast-paced
arcade mode
the mercenaries the mode takes the
combat of the village
slaps a timer on it and focuses it on
scoring points
the mercenaries is a fun side activity
in its own right always daring you to
get a higher score
by balancing taking down as many enemies
as you can and trying to complete one of
its given levels as fast as you can
it demonstrates how tight the combat in
village can be
although at times it can be held back a
bit by the slow underwater feeling of
movement around the battlefield
resident evil 7 was an excellent return
to the horror roots of the franchise
with some coming new ideas similarly
village is an intelligent reimagination
of the best action elements
of resident evil though it captures some
of the same things that made
re7 such a breath of fresh air village
uses new takes on the ideas of the past
to evolve into its own unique creature
resident evil has had many faces and
even the lack of one
over its 25 years of existence i've seen
this franchise
transform mold and redefine itself over
and over and over again
being everything from a teeth grinding
horror man house to a co-op
over the top hollywood action romp to
most recently
an absolute thirst trap wow i've seen
the franchise take detours into
different genres
set pieces and concepts some more
successful than others
and everything the franchise has
attempted accomplished
and even failed at is in resident evil
village
one way or another from a genre defining
breakthrough to some of the more
debatable entries resident evil village
is the most
resident evil game of them all let me
break this down
the foundation of resident evil village
lies on well
the actual village it's a sprawling
maze-like area with dead ends locked
doors and obtuse paths
but as the game progresses it connects
to the other areas unraveling new ones
to be discovered rewarding the player
with keys and items that compel them
to backtrack and re-explore it this was
a trope defined by the franchise's very
first
entry back in 1996 and it was a
revolution for horror games
and the first to define a genre the
survival horror genre
it took elements from adventure games
with exploration backtracking
and item-based puzzles and then applied
survival to
it by giving the player very limited
resources and enemies that soaked up
that precious
precious ammunition it was a slow paced
slog
through a maze-like environment of
narrow hulls forcing the player to make
life or death choices around every
corner of the confusingly designed
oswell
spencer mansion this is a characteristic
that would come and go through the
franchise with backtracking
and puzzles being last seen most
prominently in the fourth entry in the
series code veronica back in 2000.
it did make its grand return in resident
evil 7 but
even then the exploration was pale in
comparison to 1
2 and veronica that is until
resident evil village the village opens
and unravels similarly to the original
oswell mansion from one and the raccoon
city police department from two
or even more accurately like code
veronica's european gothic palace
and victorian mansion especially
considering its similar aesthetic to
lady dimetresk's castle
in resident evil village speaking of big
lady d let's talk about being chased
as you navigate the halls of
demotresque's castle she and her
daughters will stalk and follow you as
you desperately try to find keys and
items to unlock and open other areas
this iconic and terrifying
characteristic comes straight from
resident evil 3 nemesis resident evil 3
threw a wrench in the tropes that one
and two had created trading off the slow
pacing for
urgency and paranoia that big baddie
nemesis could bust through at any moment
a towering invincible foe that stalks
you constantly
ramping up the pressure when you least
expect it
like many ideas of the resident evil
franchise the mechanic of constantly
being pursued
wouldn't make a return until again
resident evil 7
with jack baker but it wasn't fully
mastered until resident evil
2 remake with mr x the resident evil 2
remake took jack baker's stalking
mechanic
and launched it to the nth degree with
mr x making him a towering silent goon
that slammed through anything to get you
mrx did make an appearance on the og
resident evil 2 during the b scenario
but not to the same degree as nemesis
and capcom
but at full force in the remake lady
dimitrisk is the embodiment
of both jack baker and mr x a family
woman just
looking after her own while also being
an intimidatingly huge individual big
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up real hard energy
while you're traversing villages many
different environments there'll be
treasure to find
animals to hunt and this jolly old fella
to find solace and as you sell items
upgrade weapons and buy new ones that
you can organize in your tetris-like
inventory
all of this is thanks to resident evil
4. residual 4 ripped the franchise away
from its fixed camera angles expanded
your arsenal and turn the harrowing odds
against one zombie up to 11
favoring overwhelming stress over pure
horror
a near copy of village's encounters with
a lichens
especially in its opening sequence when
you're overwhelmingly outnumbered and
have to barricade yourself into a house
four introduce the tetris-like inventory
case the treasure hunting
currency and a merchant to sell items
with most of these mechanics are
defining a four's identity
and interestingly never appeared in the
franchise again
that is until now with village some of
four's influences on village
may not be as apparent as others however
probably the most notorious area
in village is house beneviento which not
only features an adorable baby but
these terrifying ghost dolls which
aren't
entirely new to the franchise while four
was in development it had gone through
several different prototypes until
coming to what it is today
one internal version of the game was
known as the hallucination version
in this prototype build there was a room
known simply as
the doll room where leon kennedy would
fight against these pesky
19th century porcelain dolls while this
didn't end up making the cut for
resident evil 4
it was revived and cemented in village
leaning full
force into the supernatural elements
that resident evil only toyed with
behind the curtains
and it gets to be a little nice wink and
nod to us resident evil nerds who caught
it
and with no reasonable transition let's
talk about chris redfield
an overarching plot device in resident
evil village is chris
who swoops into the opening moments of
the game killing ethan's wife and
kidnapping his baby
chris is among the longest standing
characters in the franchise first
appearing in resident evil 1 alongside
jill valentine
but the game to have the most defining
impact on his character shaping him
into the bulky military head that he is
now
is resident evil 5. taking him from the
soft face boy from resident evil 1 and
code veronica and establishing
his military attitude and muscles
mechanically village didn't really take
that much from the co-op focused 5.
aside from carrying the weight of
redfield's pecs but when resident evil 6
rolled around
it had completely launched the franchise
into full-blown hollywood antics with
over-the-top action
and a sprawling cast of characters that
make even a soap opera jealous
village captures six essence at its
finest near the closing hours when we
step into the shoes of chris tricep
redfield and go
buck wild on waves of likens all call of
duty style all of which comes to a close
with
a mushroom cloud while resident evil 6
is notoriously divisive among fans for
being a
full-on hollywood action game it seems
that village couldn't help itself from
going
a little off the rails once again but
hey at least it didn't have a
zombie trx monster thing right
obviously resident evil village carried
a lot over from its predecessor resident
evil 7. while seven softly returned to
its exploration and backtracking roots
its biggest contribution to the
franchise was its changed to a first
person perspective
resident evil 7 was the first true
reimagining the franchise had seen in a
decade since resident
iv but this time around making it first
person leaning all in on horror
and lightly attempting to revisit the
franchise's dna with an
emphasis on tight spaces exploration and
arbitrary locked doors
this is something that village doubles
down on more interesting is how the game
is structured
showcasing resident evil 7's antagonists
as a family front and center
with each foe having their own distinct
area to explore and maneuver through
a prominent trait carried over into
village's narrative structure when being
introduced to the four lords
resident evil 7 felt like an attempt to
reposition the franchise with a new
generation
and revisit old concepts in a way that
was more palatable
with modern gaming trends it would have
been risky for capcom to put new players
against a sprawling
intricate mansion filled with puzzles
and backtracking tropes that hadn't been
seen in mainstream
aaa games for decades at this point but
after seven's success
those very elements of backtracking item
searching and exploration came back full
force in resident evil 2 remake resident
evil 2 remake was a no
holds barred representation of what
classic resident evil exploration
and inventory management was but built
into the modern age
and now making a grander more expansive
return
in village lastly we need to talk about
resident evil lore because
village is just bursting at the seams
with it in the final hours of the game
it is revealed that the main villain
mother miranda's existence
recontextualizes the backstory of the
entire franchise
but no other game has made a similar
contribution other than code veronica
one that i believe helped define
resident evil's absurd and complicated
lore that we know
oh so well today resident evil has grown
to have a soap opera like backstory that
spans
hundreds of years involving nazi-like
virologists cloning a strained families
and bio-organic terrorism
and veronica was the first to take it
all and put it front
and center introducing rather theatrical
and
eccentric villains opening the gates
beyond just oswell spencer's madness and
introducing edward
ashford a character like spencer fixated
on cloning and biochemical shenanigans
basically code veronica's ashford family
walk so resume before salazar could run
and village's four lords could soar and
in many ways village's four lords while
still an iteration on seven's baker
family
feels closely akin in their theatrics
and over-the-top personas
to code veronica's ashford family
especially in the end of village when we
learn mother miranda's impact on the
entire franchise's lore
which is a lot to impact this is similar
to the impact the ashford family had on
resident evil's lore
that interlaced alongside oswell spencer
veronica had the most deepening effect
on the game's lore at that time
just as village has now causing a ripple
effect
for what's to come the future of the
franchise now up to this point with each
new installment resin evil has
introduced a new idea
some of which were iterated on for
sequels to come
while others were left behind as the
genre shaped and molded
resident evil village on the other hand
has left none of those ideas
behind more than any resident evil
before it village does the most to
embody
everything the franchise has been up to
this point
village is a culmination of all of them
every single element
wrapped up and stapled together whether
it works well
that's up to you to decide but
unabashedly
and of course as a resident of apologist
at times i love it
and while it does feel like a
frankenstein's monster
it is an encapsulation of the
franchise's 25 years
and for that reason alone it makes
village one of the most special resident
evil games
today and it does a lot to push the
franchise forward while doubling down
on its past
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i am storm incarnate
my queen my king
divine beasts with grace replete
shall meet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and
foreign
[Applause]
anonymous
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the capcom e3 showcase i'm
your host rachel querico
aka seltzer and i'll be your guide as we
walk through the latest releases
news and updates from capcom we'll hear
from the resident evil village team
share some news from the world of
monster hunter and get the latest on ace
attorney
then we'll wrap up with some updates
from our friends at capcom fighters
so what are we waiting for let's get
started our first stop today
resident evil village the resident evil
franchise continues to pioneer the
latest and greatest in survival horror
the team has been blown away by the
response to resident evil village
which launched last month it brought the
world another chapter in this
decades-long story as the franchise
celebrates its
25th anniversary this year i'm honored
to be able to introduce
suyoshi konda producer on resident evil
village
with a special message for the fans
[Music]
she's everything to me
[Music]
i think it's time you left things in my
hands
go on rest now
[Music]
hi everyone my name is tsuyoshi kanda
producer on resident evil village
i wanted to take this opportunity to
thank everyone who's prayed since we
last came in may
we hope you are enjoying this new
chapter in survival horror
as a reminder everyone who purchases
resident evil village will gain free
access to our online multiplayer title
resident evil reverse
where players go head to head with their
favorite resident evil heroes and
bioweapons
i'm now happy to announce that resident
evil arrivers will go live next month
across all supported platforms so head
into the freight to celebrate the
resident evil 25th anniversary
thank you condesant for that wonderful
update next up
some long-awaited news from the world of
monster hunter
whether it's adventuring alongside
monsters or battling them with friends
we've got something for you first let's
dive into the brand new story based rpg
entry to the series
monster hunter stories 2 wings of ruin
[Laughter]
[Music]
this was his fate
red may have been strong and skilled but
against the awesome power of nature
he was merely a man he never stood a
chance
all around things just kept getting
worse
but i heard that guardian rather had
survived
and returned to hekolo island
i went there to see red's old monster
again
then of course that's when i met you
[Music]
you were given red's kinship stone and
now a rathalos egg
this is destiny
this is the legendary monster raised
wing
arthur the monster with the wings of
ruin
it's said that a beat of its wings can
bring about wage
destruction many people believe there's
a connection between the strange
happenings and the wings of ruin
the pits are appearing everywhere and
they're emitting strange light
[Music]
what's this whole idea of forming
kinship with monsters
how do you control them it's not about
control
monsters help riders of their own will
and the bonds between monsters
and riders are just like your bond with
sukina
what kind of power does rather really
have
why are all of these pits appearing and
who are those people who want to take
rather for themselves
all i have are questions if there's
worry or doubt in your voice
rafa will become anxious too
he needs to know that you will protect
him no matter what
i can sense the flames of his life force
weakening
the burden of such great power
it's too much for his body to bear
[Music]
a voice can you hear it
[Music]
riders can bond with monsters
surely you can groove with fellow humans
they have the power of kinship they're
friends
they're monsters humans carry the
strength of everyone they meet
that makes them strong my friends here
taught me that
i believe in the strength of humanity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looks pretty epic right and how about
that announcement
the canine companion palomut from
monster hunter rise will be joining
monster hunter stories 2
as one of the new monsters in the first
free title update coming soon after the
game's release
you can get an early peek at the game
with the monster hunter stories 2
wings of ruin trial version starting on
june 25th
which also carries your progress over to
the full game release just a few weeks
later on july 9th
that's not the only way to join the hunt
millions of you made monster hunter rise
a huge success earlier this year
and we have even more content coming
including a new collaboration on the
rise
let's find out more
let's go
[Music]
this is for my fellow hunters
[Music]
emerged
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is like my second home you think you can
take only
[Music]
there has never been a better time to be
a monster hunter fan
with all the new updates to monster
hunter rise and the launch of monster
hunter stories
2 this summer we can't wait to hear
about your own stories of adventure
well that's not the only thing capcom
has in store for us this july
fans of phoenix wright will have new
chapters to explore
with the release of the great ace
attorney chronicles
north american and european future
attorneys will finally be able to get
their hands on the great ace attorney
adventures
and the great ace attorney to resolve
which were previously only available in
japan you'll travel back in time to the
late 19th century japan and london
to play as ryonosuke naruhodo phoenix
wright's ancestor in this action-packed
prequel
now let's hear more about the
so then let story unravel this mystery
[Applause]
welcome to the center of the world
great britain's mighty capital london
this country is incredible
i will become a lawyer i have to
so then let us unravel this mystery and
discover what events
led to this curious murder who are you
turlock shows you must have heard of me
we must solve this case let us engage in
the art of deduction
well what happened here
[Music]
it would seem the truth is now
tantalizingly close
the defense demands its right to a
cross-examination
objection your testimony completely
contradicts the facts
objection my lord with all due respect
this is an outrage
[Music]
you're the best lawyer in the world
[Music]
so we have ten new cases and 8 mini
escapades
where you can take on the role of a
defense attorney now
we all want to see some gameplay right
let's take a closer first look at two
gameplay features
new to the franchise in the great ace
attorney chronicles
dance of deduction and summation
examination
hello i'm jonathan capcom's marketing
brand manager for the great ace attorney
chronicles
so this is the capital of great britain
where to this supreme court in whitehall
if you wouldn't mind
the capcom team is thrilled to present
two new gameplay features
dance production and summation
examination
coming to the ace attorney series
while investigating to prove your
client's innocence
players will come across conspicuous
situations that require further
examination
with the help of ryonovsky's legal aid
susanto and the brilliance of deduction
from detective herlock
herlock will proceed to present his
logic and reasoning spectacular
a grandiose yet flawed series of
conjectures
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
will then discuss to correct the flaws
in herlock's deductions
[Music]
at this point players will be prompted
to search for clues that help identify
the errors
in the detective's logic and reveal the
truth to the mystery
[Music]
as players present new evidence and
observations herlock will amend his
deductions
based on the new information
upon uncovering the truth ryunosuke and
herlock enter into a semi-metaphorical
semi-literal dance that brings them to
the conclusion of the dance of deduction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in courtroom battles players will
attempt to convince six jurors of the
innocence of their client
their progress will be displayed and
represented by two scales of justice
one black representing a guilty verdict
and one white representing a not guilty
verdict
objection in summation examination
take the stand to face off against the
jurors
all of whom provide explanations as to
why they've reached their guilty verdict
[Music]
you'll have to identify conflicting
statements and sway the jury in your
favor
examine each statement carefully and
select two contradicting jurors
to call out the flaws in their logic
[Music]
[Music]
objections
be ready to provide evidence from the
court record to help prove the
contradiction in their claims
when you successfully point out one of
these contradictions among the jurors
you might just change their minds too
with a slam of their
fist each juror you persuade will send a
fiery ball towards the scales above and
literally tip the scales of justice in
your favor
bring each contradiction to light and
persuade the jury to help prove your
client's innocence
objection my lord with all due respect
this is an outrage
this has just been a small taste of the
exciting new gameplay features
in the great ace attorney chronicles we
are very excited to get this game in the
hands of both
new fans and die hard fans alike
thanks for watching
[Music]
it already seems like i have a bunch of
games to catch up on
there are some exciting new adventures
and titles to look forward to
well that's a look at the new premieres
from capcom but what about esports
let's close out today's showcase with a
few words from two of the stars of
capcom fighters
rob tv and vicious they'll tell us
what's been going on with capcom esports
including updates on the capcom pro tour
intel world open street fighter league
and all the other content on capcom
fighters
over to you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on everybody and welcome to
the capcom esports presentation for e3
2021 my name is vicious commentator for
the capcom pro tour as well as street
fighter league
here with competitive street fighter 5
player and host extraordinaire
hollywood rob tv what's going on rob oh
my goodness vicious
host extraordinaire that just sounds
beautiful it has a ring to it
and i think that's the perfect word to
describe what we have for everyone today
street fighter 5
capcom e3 it just feels right and you
feel the electricity in the air
nice nice
nasty and there might be some people at
home [ __ ] who don't fully know
what competitive street fighter 5 is the
longer the short of it is this
we travel all around the world state the
state country to country
and we try to bring our opponent's life
bar from 100
all the way down to zero and feel pretty
goddamn good doing it that's right rob
if you think you're the best in your
region
sign up for capcom pro tour to prove it
and become possibly
a world champion at street fighter 5 the
double perfect the way he looked at the
camera
whatever expect another man's controller
so in this year's cpc
overall it's a series of tournaments
that have
five thousand dollars on the line for
each tournament but
that money alone that's not the big
that's not what's really at stake here
it's about making it to the grand daddy
of them all capcom
cut
[Music]
item just reset in grand finals of
cup so behind me you can see in all of
its glory
the capcom pro tour 2021 official stage
and set
and that's a place that you are very
very familiar with that's right we take
all of our events and broadcast it live
from this stage and we check out all of
the top competitors from each and every
one of these regions
and speaking of the capcom pro tour has
shaped up a lot 2021 we have 32
events going on in the capcom pro tour
spanning across
19 different territories so there's so
many opportunities
for players from around the world to get
that ticket into capcom cup this season
i'm absolutely excited because again
that is a big change from what 2020 was
into what we could expect for 2021.
and mago is your first qualifier for
japan for the capcom pro tour not only
can you catch the capcom pro tour live
on the capcom fighters channel you can
do so on a plethora of platforms we have
it on twitch
youtube twitter and facebook of course
if you don't catch it live you can also
check out the vods
for all the competitive studying you
would need to become a successful street
fighter 5 player
as well as catching some of the
community focused content that we have
on capcom fighters we have
no neutral the official pre-show of the
capcom pro tour
we have sets where we take players from
around the world and play off in an
exhibition first to ten
not only that actually we do have street
fighter league that's happened
season after season non-stop action six
teams of three
duke it out in this battle tournament
series to see who will walk away with
the championship
and the 150 thousand dollar prize pool
street fighter league is something that
you don't want to miss because normally
we only have
1v1 content but now you actually have
your teammates at your back
and every decision that you make is not
just about you anymore look for more
news on street fighter league later this
year
it's okie time what's gonna happen he
checks takes the movement
what's happening it's so good
let's not forget the intel world opening
is happening
right now top players representing 11
regions around the world are competing
for their place
in the world finals happening next month
be sure to check out the official
website for more information
including current standings and
broadcast schedule
to commemorate this event everyone who
logged in during this period will
receive an exclusive
competitor title and dojo object you do
not
want to miss this i highly recommend
everyone to stay
tuned for future capcom pro tour
updates on the capcom fighters channel
and again we've had so many events so
far we started off with the japan
region we've had a couple of more events
going on afterwards but the action
does not stop in fact we're going to be
continuing off with the midwest
region for the capcom pro tour i know
you're definitely excited about that 100
i mean of course your boy is from ohio
make sure you guys tune in to see the
tournament you do not
want to miss some of the best street
fighter 5 players in the world
compete head to head
i dare you to find better street fighter
i dare you
this is a game about being a world
warrior
obviously they got a rivalry i'm the
best in the world
this game has changed the lives of so
many people here
that's what i'm talking about i told you
it's going to go to the limit
of the people this is the ultimate
street fighter 5 experience
this is capcom
thanks guys it's been a really exciting
season so far and i can't wait to see
how this plays out on the road to capcom
cup
remember to check out capcom fighters
twitch and youtube channels for more
information and watch the latest matches
so that's a wrap for capcom at e3 this
year let's recap what we all saw
resident evil village is back with the
latest installment of the survival
horror experience and reverse as part of
the franchise's 25th anniversary
we have new adventures to embark on in
the world of monster hunter
with monster hunter stories 2 wings of
ruin
and monster hunter rise and don't forget
to go back in time with the great ace
attorney chronicles
to tap into the family history of
phoenix wright and solve new cases
finally don't miss out on the esports
fun make sure you catch
the latest matches with capcom fighters
there really is something for everyone
here today
but don't go anywhere yet join the
conversation on twitter and make sure
you check out the capcom virtual booth
on the e3 portal to watch
all these videos again and more i'm
rachel querico aka seltzer
thank you for being part of the capcom
experience at e3 this year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you